j.t brubaker moments ago took the field
here at pnc park for his 23rd start of
the season as you mentioned 23rd start
of the year he's 4-13 with a 5-4-9 era
looking for him to get back on track
tonight there we go that's another one
he gets the strikeout completed
catcher to first seems to be a pitch to
lately well if you can keep it down like
jt does right here two strikes got a
chance of getting under the barrel and
getting help haven smith makes his first
start of the series and that was lying
into right center and he came on and
made the catch securing it with both
hands looking over toward ben gamelin
right that's brian reynolds drewball
cabrera is coming up
ground ball
we got a guy there
yes indeed that's javis
good start
nine pitch inning for jt brubaker
retiring the diamondbacks the d-back
starter tonight madison bumgarner who
can get his record back over 500 for the
first time since the middle of may
we talked about his last start against
the phillies a season high eight innings
gave up one run on three hits he gave up
a lead off double to gene segura and did
not give up another base hit until
leading off the eighth inning a double
by ronald torre as he was on top of his
game against the fields
michael chavez the second baseman a
right-hand bat in there will bad lead
off for the pirates
hit on the ground to short right there
is nick ahmed slings it to first one
pitch one out
brian hayes
called strike three two up two down for
bad bump brian reynolds
one deep to center dalton varsha was
there
three outs on six pitches a great start
for mad bomb no score afterward kelly
one for two hit by a pitch
drew a walk last night the diamondbacks
catcher there we go
good slider second strikeout yeah that
was a great pitch and pitch selection
and execution so coming off of a couple
of fastballs
to throw that slider breaking the other
way and to have it down look here jacob
stalin's got the glove down and he threw
it right where he wanted it got a
strikeout go soft away you can run your
sinker away you can stay in there i'd
probably go softer sink away
bounces it to third and just one play
for key brian hayes and he looked over
towards second
and it may be a bit of a surprise to see
varsho as close to first as he was and
he had to put little oomph
on that toss over to moran ball had a
little bit of english to it and i think
you're right barco getting out of the
box and running the way he did kind of
caught keep brian hayes by surprise but
got enough on it look like he got him
they will not challenge but boy is that
close
one of the better hitting
pitchers his generation madison
bumgarner even though he's batting just
133.
19 career home runs
line to third right at hayes he was
right on it but that ends the inning
comes set and his 2-1
swing and a miss
down and then slider the ball got away
from stongs throw to third safe that's
awfully close runner moves up 90 feet
that's the most important thing into
third goes rojas so the infield will
creep in and it is a wild pitch this
will be the eighth pitch coming up to
pavon smith infield is up nobody out
here's the pitch
oh wow drug him out one away starts off
the plate kind of runs back over and you
see smith kind of get handcuffed with a
runner a third and one out wow how about
that strikeout tori lavello probably not
thrilled with that at bat pirates are
three and two two outs two men in
scoring position it started with the
double by rojas off the wall he went to
third on a wild pitch back-to-back
strikeouts a walk another wild pitch the
3-2
swing and a miss he struck him out that
ends the inning michael chavis will lead
it off for the pirates in the third
and on q michael chavis hits his first
pirate home run first pitch swinging and
it's one nothing chavis clears the deck
with a cannonball
welcome to pittsburgh michael chavis
triple by hayes nobody out
broken bad pop up and is hayes gonna
test yes he will the throw from peralta
will never get him sacrifice fly for
brian reynolds and it's two nothing
gamble aboard to start the fourth and
the batter is kevin newman
newman gets one up in the air deep to
left center it's near the notch peralta
has got it
david peralta into the wall the flip to
var show they get it back in david
peralta full speed into that wall in
left center and somehow he hung on
anthony alford
and alford hits this one deep to left
peralta at it again he leaps he can't
get this one he goes into the seats
offer clears the deck cannonball coming
his first of the season
four nothing that's what we want to see
a couple more runs make madison
bumgarner work and throw some pitches
get that pitch count up see if we can
get into that arizona bullpen
great job by offer look at the numbers
there exit velocity 106. 46 degree
launch angle 370 feet
i love the aggressiveness we see out of
this pirates ball club right now irish
league four nothing here with the sixth
van meter has walked in flight out
that's a fair ball can hayes make this
play on the first the strats he got him
every night it seems
he wows you with his defense and the
great stretch by chavis on the other end
both sides of this
keep ryan comes in and
like you said greg every night something
new but watch this stretch right here
look at that from chavis love it raquel
martay announced as the pinch hitter for
peralta against the lefty shree
and with the way cattell has been just
killing the ball from the right side
chance to get him in there against the
lefty trying to get cabrera home from
third at least with one out
turns on that one and launches it way
out of here katel
continues to crush lefties and it's four
to two that's why you want him in there
right there
108 miles an hour off the bat
the seventh of the year for cattell
fastball inside corner
don't even think about it rojas bats
with the bases empty the tying run
remains on deck pirates lead four to two
here in the ninth
shortstop newman and raise the jolly
roger again
back-to-back knights
over the d-backs
chris stratton the save
you